I understand like why men are walking  away from marriage because they get a  bad deal  and that's that's like one thing I  didn't when I first started watching red  pill content I was like I grew up in a  two-parent household and my parents are  still married so I never understood like  why men would walk away from Marriage  until I realized it's like a contract  the women are paid to leave yeah and you  can take half of his earnings which  doesn't even make sense like why are you  entitled to half of the money that he  made and you don't even have kids and so  and on top of that like the average age  of first marriage in the UK is 31 here  it's like 28 for women and so men value  Purity and youth and they don't get  either of those things yeah from women  today so it's like what a mess yeah yeah  I understand why you know